i was when i was like i don't know 2006
i don't know what year i mean how old
exactly i was but i jumped off the
mountain bridge in san bernardino
through the metro link is you know the
metro link the mount vernon bridge
the santa fe i jumped off that bridge
it's a 40-foot drop
you mean this is the end result for me
jumping off the mountain and bridge
is see
it's like the story a rock went through
my head right here
i could stick this much of my finger
through my head
yeah my back case in my hand because i
hit the rubber tracks
i hit the rubber traps walking through
my head just became my club
and i talked like this now you mean
i was in a coma for about six months
they told me that i would never have
kids
i might never walk you know they told me
a lot of things
and i have three beautiful kids after
the fact you know what i mean
[Laughter]
all right florencia florescent where are
you from
i'm originally from arizona arizona san
carlos
yeah and
what uh tell me about your family do you
live for see
my mom my mom she was um
beautiful lady i mean i didn't spend too
much time with her
my mom was pregnant with me she got two
life sentences
she wrote she had two life sentences
seven months pretty with me
two life sentences yeah so my mom had me
in prison
you mean and um i i didn't know her
growing up
she never reached out to me growing up
um
at the time my my mom's incarceration
well a
conviction her and my dad both got
convicted
my dad got completely of a lesser charge
we ate in the bathing accessory after
the fact
and but my mom was the one who was who
was
my dad tried to ate and debated and it
had been insist
and they gave him 13 years he joined
that my mom never brought me and we
never
tried to miss out to me anything my dad
did
you know so where were you who raised
you my dad's mom
yeah my dad's mom and um
she did the best she could you know meet
him just the circumstances it was me and
my seven brothers
and plus
she had six other kids other than my mom
you know me
so she had me she had a lot of grandkids
and
a lot of stuff to attend for me
and so uh
growing up it was me and my seven
brothers in one house which is my mom
and dad's house my mom and dad lived on
the same block
as my grandma on the same street just
one block away
same so we me my brothers lived
in my mom and dad's house and my grandma
10 10 folk to us
me from visiting and making sure we ate
and we
cleaned house for school
um she was there you mean touched me in
the night remember my bedtime stories
you mean mission nobody hurt me um
then when i was 13 my dad came home from
prison and she was like oh your dad is
home you mean
now you mean you guys will be okay
well me not knowing my mom at the time
you mean and me being the youngest i
asked you
do i look like my mom you know i'm not
knowing and
one thing led to another and he started
to touch me
but made no father [ __ ] you mean
and i was looking for something to get
him off of me
you mean and he wouldn't stop
and the more i stabbed him he didn't
stop he penetrated me
until seven stab wounds later
really penetrated me the whole way
through every step when i started seven
different times
i stabbed him with it with it with this
with a steak knife
at that you're stabbing him with a
sticker i cuz i made a mistake dinner
i mean i asked him what he wanted we
just came over from prison i mean that's
my daddy
he's having an intercourse with you
you're stabbing
yeah and he penetrated me the whole way
through
i mean and i'm like i'm your daughter
you may get off me
well he took a [ __ ] on himself
and when he started to cover blood and
he's like oh [ __ ] you're my daughter
you mean i can't say that
he didn't know it was me i can't say he
didn't know it was me i know it has a
few questions
to escalate or to arouse a few things
you mean in him that i don't know
but
when he died i just pushed him off me
even jumped in the shower grab some ice
and ran i mean i was scared it was 13.
i didn't know what to do you died right
there yeah
yeah and because i took a shower
i watched away all the evidence you mean
because of my way i lived guilty
you mean they gave me juvenile life
juvenile life i mean at 13 years old
i was released at 22 you know
and that was real hard i mean
my grandma told me that the day her son
died they her grandmother died
and she meant that to fullest you mean
to this day she means that
i can't say i blame her from my mother's
point of view i
you mean understand a mother's point of
view i understand from a granddaughter's
point of view
i don't understand i don't think i ever
will
but i had to come and realize that i
wasn't the sick one i wasn't the one
you know i wasn't the one that was
messed up in the head
you mean i was the one who stopped
i mean i wasn't just stopped it you mean
because it was a family secret
i wasn't the first in my family he
checked you mean i was the last one he
churches
and even though i regret it with
everything in my life that's the only
thing i ever regret
because at the end of the day we have to
meet tell my dad you know me
it's hard it's a hard pure to live with
women
because it's like actually with my
grandma me and his sisters
my brothers you know i mean
[Music]
it wasn't my call to do what i did
but i promised on my side of god
everything i loved
i wasn't trying to kill him i really
wasn't i just want him off me
so once i got out of prison you know a
lot of time had passed
i mean but in my mind as
i got out it it became
a brand new beginning in the center i'm
saying
that the time i spent the juvenile life
i spent in prison i was able
to push it behind me from 14 to 22
i was able to push it behind me now that
i'm out
i'm trying to see my family you mean and
i'm trying to
you mean go around my family they're
like we don't want you around here you
know i mean i'm like
i'm the baby you mean what are you
talking about you mean
you all i am
you mean my dad was the only son
out of five girls you know what i mean
[Music]
hi i had kids you know and their life
they're married
my grandma didn't have seen my kids my
grandmother never seen my kids
the whole time i had them never
i catch a case out here on central in
2010
i mean six females down trying to jump
me you
tell me what am i doing out there you
know i mean i'm not i'm not black i mean
i'm messing and i'm not supposed to be
out there serving hear me
so i started the first time to come at
me the other five are still
fighting me but we all separate
when we all separate they go their way
out on my way
well i guess sometime during that night
their friend had died
and they told on me so about five
o'clock in the morning i'm gonna pull it
out of my tent
turn about how much i detectives want to
talk to me
okay you know
i was talking about manicure nobody you
mean
i'm sleeping you mean i was in a little
fight but that was it you mean nothing
well um because on the outcome of that
fight you mean someone died in
you know and you're guilty you're the
suspect
the suspect there's five of them it's
one of me how am i the suspect do you
mean
their word against mine you mean my
previous conviction
for my dad even though they shouldn't
have been able to politically since
juvenile case
under the same process and the thing um
you mean
create same motive you mean the same
kind you mean the same
saying so
they i took ten 10 and 85 percent
i go in i can't cross my mom
you mean and he was in prison with her
mom i'm in the same place with my mom
my money says 30-something years after
the fact what i mean
and i'm like why why did you never write
me what you mean
what did i do she was able to say she
didn't know me
she didn't know how i was really at how
i felt you mean that he was scared
i understand i mean i understand
you mean same time you're my mom i love
you i mean you
you he wasn't me it was for you
you mean and so we get uh somewhat close
you mean during this eight years we able
to well bond
i mean i get out december
16th
while i was incarcerated
[Music]
my son dies may 31st my first
may 31st 2018.
he gets
and he dies
and i'm like
you know you mean my baby my
you firstborn he's he's 12 years old
about to be 13.
we died one day before his birthday he
died
and
when i went to the funeral because i was
almost home you mean i was able to go to
the funeral
my grandma's in he was in the kill my
grandma when he passed
my grandma didn't tell me now you know
what it feels like she lose the sun
when i was a kid playing in the front
yard in the lab
you understand what i'm saying there's
other kids there my daughter tells me
tells me my mom i was the day my my
brother that i was mad mom
mad my mom was why we used to met
because i want to paint the back of the
kids with it i want to play in the back
with the rest of the kids
but grandma says we have seen the fun
so my daughter's telling me this and i'm
like what do you mean
the rest of the kids everybody in the
background
me and my brother only wants the front
they play football the ball on the
street so i tried to go get it
but quick was the numbers you don't want
in the street papa's numbers
he's been a big brother you know he go
he
they say he looks both ways no cars
as soon as he grabs the ball the car
comes out of nowhere boom he dies
being locked up not being able to be the
kid like i was supposed to
show me nobody take care of your kids
away you're going to take care of your
kids
you know what i mean i can't stay my
grandma tesla had my son killed
no but when she made a statement now you
know what i feel like she was a son
kind makes you feel like she was
she wanted something to happen you know
she wanted me to feel her pain
you know i'm saying
and oh do i feel it
i've always felt it though
he was my dad at the end of the day
he wouldn't stop penetrating me if he
would have stopped penetrating me
i would have stopped stabbing you know
what i mean
so i come home
my sunday is may 31st his birthday is
june 1st
you meet has a baby for his birthday
i come home in december and i leave my
mom
to meet i'm going to send you let me see
your boxing
meeting call let me know i got you my
mom i love you
you mean okay come back and see you get
me
and let me say oh goodbyes
two months later my mom passes she is
sick and let me see i caught her
abscessed
in prison i don't know what the abscess
is it's like a bottle of poison from
slammy
what happened was the boil popped from
inside it ran and went straight to her
heart with her bloodstream to her heart
and it killed her instantly
instantly so i get a phone call saying
my mom had this pass and i'm like i just
left what are you talking about
she just passed you know i just left
there like not even two months ago you
know me
and there was the fact it's okay it's
okay she wasn't within 37 years
she has to live now you know i mean she
don't have to be trapped no more
you mean misses free
so my husband
who the one who had my kids before i
went to prison
the one who dropped my kids off at my
grandma's
he feels so bad you know he benched his
outfit he said never take the babies
there hissy just kept them home you know
i mean
he he catches the case he goes to vegas
kidnaps two white people
when we get too frustrated kidnapped and
saw what they left with his conspiracy
to human robbery robbery
um imposing any public officer he puts
up a baby case
where they give him life they gave him
life
mind you i'm uh
i'm six months to the gate at this time
but my cousin when my husband caught
life i was
five months to the gate about five
months to come home
when he got life when he got like
the me they checked the house they mean
the owners said that we
fit forfeit the property because neither
one of us was there we abandoned it
you know that you'll go housing
all our belongings you mean now when i
come home
prison i come home to what
nothing i come home to two kids
that my brother has
temporary custody of you know me
you know different college temporary
guardianship
because i'm in prison and my brother's
in prison my husband's a person
i got a person and my son had just
passed and
my husband went to prison
they took everything everything we owned
is gone and i'm like now where'd i go
i don't want to come back down here this
is where everything began
and i'm like i'm looking everybody's
like no you can't come here you can't
come here you mean
i'm like i'm you guys family you mean me
all i have
you mean i don't know nobody else but
you guys
i'm sorry for my dad i'm sorry
what are we expecting to do you know
what he's supposed to do
no no we just better stop you don't come
together
so against everything i want
already back down here
so i i get a tent and i'm like man
i'm okay so since i call my case and
sanctuary
let's not go there let's come to the
other side
you mean anything past that people you
know should be okay for me
well i come to sixth and quacker and i
pictured my chain
and i instantly fall into the line of
the limit of
the same stuff i was doing before i got
busted
i mean but throwing in that case back
then i was smoking crack real heavy
real heavy i was moving crack cocaine
you know
and i was i was real bad into my
addiction i would take the dope man
i would rob the dope man you know me tax
take his whole sack stick my mouth
and tell him look you can either beat me
up or wait for me to pay you
the choice is yours sometimes i got beat
up sometimes they waiting
but i i was seeing that crack at the end
of the day you know me
and so this time coming home
i didn't have that craving which i thank
god for it
you mean i could smell it it don't tempt
me
i could be around it i don't want it you
know what i'm saying
i must have came home i came home from
prison with about an eight ball of
crystal
and about five balloons which is heroin
and i came home from prison and i
put my chin up and i suck started with
what i came home with
now mind you i'm i'm i came home from
prison with this you don't mean i didn't
buy it when i got home
and you'd be surprised how much drugs
are in prison
i mean you will be surprised
but um so i come out here and
they're like well um you gotta have
blocks now this is my blog this
summer's the block that's a block this
block right here technically on this
side they don't belong to nobody
but it cost me it belongs to somebody
you know and i'm like
i don't forgot none of that you know i
mean this is skid row it's foodland
you know what i mean don't nobody own
this [ __ ] you mean
i will strictly go back to that same
mentality when
i caught my case i'm not in michigan i'm
native american i can do what the [ __ ] i
want to do you know i mean
and so i go with that mentality once
again
and so i'm selling the
the products that i have the crystal mat
and the black
and i was sending some children um by 10
o'clock tonight you have to get off the
block
who who asked me off the block now mind
you i already have my
i mean people who know me from the past
and i can't tell you what i mean like
things things escalate real fast and
same thing
and so they're like wow china clustering
you have to be off the block
you and my army is going to move me oh
wow this is such a such sense
okay i'm from the same place you're from
i'm going nowhere you mean you sell
black and any crack okay
at the time my black hat had already
sold so i just have to crystal meth
i don't i'm not signed into a crystal so
technically legally i'm not interfering
with the money
so to make illegal you can't get me off
the block especially
from like we're not from the same set
but we're from the same
neighborhood you know what i mean and so
he's like no i'm gonna [ __ ] you still
gotta the [ __ ]
okay bet i go to his big
he hit his the person higher than him
and i'm like man look you know me
you already know i'm with all the
business you mean like i will [ __ ] you
mean i got no sense
you mean and where whatever let's have a
stand up we have to i don't care i'm not
i'm not moving i'm not
neighborhood your neighborhood i'm not
moving
you know what i mean and i i
the way i approached it the way i came
at him man you
this is you you this is where your
money's at
the the hard and the black i'm not
interfering with them i'm not i have
nothing to do with that
i'm selling a whole different product
that you don't even mess with
so if i'm not interfering with your
money gently legally you can't kick him
off the block
especially if i'm if i'm a hustler just
like your story i mean
so when i went that route it gave me
something to stand on
you mean where he was like wow you're
right
since i don't serve that wherever i
serve
you're free you you're welcome to
you don't mean so now it's like giving
me a key like
here you mean this is this is all you
this is your
you mean this is this is your domain
what you do with it
so that starts to happen now all of a
sudden my daughter gets sick
you know me my second to the oldest
she's seven
she passed away monday i mean she had a
bump and a half
thank you daughter pastor waiting monday
last week
yes and
seven i mean she was alone in the
hospital for two months
she had a lump in her arm and they went
in then they
checked it and it came out positive for
cancer they went in to remove it you
mean
as quickly as possible before it spreads
but once they cut
open once they cut it open it
it spread it rapidly you and the sun was
saying
well i started having like mining like
seizures and minor strokes
you know and then she had a major stroke
and
she was going to come off about a week
and they're like it's not looking good
and we maybe we should put a plug and
i'm like no
you mean no you mean like
but it's
[Music]
it's not easy
you know i'm not supposed to bury my
kids
you know i'm i'm not my kids are
supposed to be
me you mean
i buried my first one last year
i buried my mom a few months ago now i'm
on wednesday i'll be burying my daughter
i had to put a plug she was in hospital
for two months that one will end the
university eighty-five percent playing
dead
you know i gave up the dope saying
i killed everything you know you know i
had to make a decision
what was my point the block and trying
to get together or
my daughter and i had to
do what was best for my family
you mean and i had to let everything go
in the meaning it's like
please don't take her please don't take
away
plenty childish so hard
because in the back of your mind you
tell yourself
but it but what if
what if none of that happens what is
wanted to say
what's gonna happen the minute they
opened it
open here everything happened so fast
oh
i have my father from the apache
clintons creepy
selfless you mean let her go you just
hold on to something that's not even
going to be there again and i'm like
how do we know you know we can't put a
plug
we can't we have to give a [ __ ]
chance
[Music]
and
when it says 85 percent brent head and
now i'm signing a paper scene that
whatever happens
at this point since i'm going against
the doctor's recommendations
i have people saying
[Music]
that whatever happens to my daughter i
can't be in the hospital
you know what i'm saying because i'm
going to kiss what the doctors recommend
the doctors recommend pulling the plug
no and so i have to sign a paper insane
i take full responsibility of
whatever happens after this
this is my daughter this is my child
this is somebody i both do you don't
mean
how am i gonna pour the pleasure so you
could die
you mean we don't know what these what
the doctor's saying they told me i would
never walk again
i want to have kids i have three
beautiful kids
you mean i only had one i'm doing
another one i only have one left and
it's like
what do you want me to do
i'm only human you know i'm not strong
i might look strong and
i'm not that strong
hey they say god will never get anything
you can't handle
you